when I was growing up I used to have a
lot of nervous ticks some of them were
really embarrassing I used to Blink a
lot constantly I used to do this with my
neck and then have to adjust with my
shoulder when I was walking I used to
always have to step on the lines or
completely avoid the lines on the
sidewalk I was also getting into a lot
of fights at my school so seeing this my
parents are really worried and it took
me to go see a child psychologist I
didn't know she was a psychologist my
parents just said I was gonna go play
games with somebody and we had some
games together and she showed me these
ink blocks and told me what do you see
in these pictures and she asked me a
bunch of questions the immediate
recommendation was that I switched
schools right away and so in grade five
I transferred to a new school called
Crescent and ended up staying there from
grade 5 all the way to graduating high
school and the ticks got better for the
most part they went away completely to
this day I still have a few minor ones
where if I'm thinking or if I'm stressed
or if I'm tired you could see my ears
move but other than that they're gone
what it really made me think about was
the importance of your environment so
your environment is either something
that builds you up that lifts your
spirits that helps you go chase your
dreams or something that squashes you
down so think about the people that you
surround yourself with think about the
TV shows you're watching and the media
that you're consuming and the place that
you go to work does your environment
build you up or squash you down changing
my environment had a dramatic impact on
the quality of my life and the
contribution to my success as an
entrepreneur and changing yours can have
the same impact for you rule number two
add more value add more value
if you want to be able to charge what
you're worth if you want to be able to
build a successful company you need to
add a ton of value the amount of money
that you make will be directly related
to how much value you're providing for
your customers how much you're helping
them out it's a pretty simple equation
executing it is difficult
but the concept is simple to understand
if you want to make more money add more
value and stop competing on price when
you compete on price alone it's a
loser's game you're not going to bring
on ideal clients you're constantly going
to be struggling to get by you're not
going to be able to hire great people
for your team you have to stop competing
on price stock start adding more value
and you're gonna love your business more
you're going to have more fun you're
going to attract much better clients
you want to work with people who
understand the value you provide and not
just cater to the guys who have no
budget who are barely paying you a tiny
profit for what you're doing rule number
three find your one word I believe
everybody has one word that they stand
for and when you figure out what that
one word is your life and your business
will change and it's not just for
marketing it's not just how you promote
yourself but it's who you surround
yourself with the team that you attract
yourself to the products and services
that you launch when I accompanied uh an
embraced believe as my one word
my business started to take off my
videos started doing insanely better I
started attracting the right people into
my team I started launching products
that made sense for people and people
really embraced and so I'm a huge
believer in it and I'm gonna give you
a quick method to how to figure out your
one word the first step is you think
about what makes you happy what are the
things that make you come alive what are
the things that you love doing and just
don't even think about what you want
your one word is yet just think about
all the things that you love doing
things you could do all day long the
things that fill your life with joy
write those things down and this isn't
just a business thing this is you
personally because you want to make this
personal for your business to be
successful
the second thing is then look at what
connects them what are all the things
that connect those things that make you
happy what's the connective tissue and
try to figure out is there one word that
can bring all those things together so
think about what your favorite movie is
your favorite book your favorite uh your
best friend growing up what you love
about your parents uh you know what
businesses you've been attracted to the
hobbies that you love doing what
connects them all together for me it's
believe you know I love Seabiscuit as a
movie which is about this Underdog horse
and Underdog jockey and Underdog trainer
Underdog owner and how they all work
together to then win a whole bunch of
races uh the songs I listen to are
always the uplifting believe kind of
positive ones those are the ones that I
gravitate towards what I love about my
parents is that they always believed in
me and told me that I was a extremely
Carmichael and I could do anything that
I wanted even if they didn't give me the
the ideas of how to start a business
they always believe that whatever
I could did I would be successful at and
taught me to believe in myself and so
it's really important and so all of
those things that I've done across my
life have been about believe and when I
encompassed that it allowed me to start
living my life on purpose with Direction
instead of just being reacting to it
rule number four be unique the thing is
in every industry is competitive right
every industry is competitive and the
key is you got to be you the key thing
that's going to make you stand out from
everybody else is you I'm trying to
cross the street as I'm saying this
that's a differentiator that's your
Market advantage and so you've got to
figure out yes you can model success yes
you can look at people who are big in
the beauty industry and look at how they
Rose and those are great examples you
gotta take what worked for them and then
make it your own you've got to find a
way to make this your business and
people will be attracted to your
personality not everybody but a certain
group of people and when I found the
best way to do it is to combine your
passions so if you love beauty that's
amazing that's awesome what else do you
love and how can you mix those two
things so for example Apple say you love
dancing right you love dancing that's
your passion besides Beauty be the
beauty person for dancers right the next
time I'm doing a photo shoot the next
time they're getting ready for a
performance
the next time they're out there uh
getting into a movie I almost got run
over by that guy
holy cow they're gonna call you right
you're making videos your American blog
posts you're tweeting about makeup and
beauty
and dancing
so that's the key that's how you do it a
couple examples that I've used before in
the video one you know if you like being
a photographer photographers are super
competitive too but say you love bowling
then you can be the photographer for
bowlers and you're going to be the
default person they go to because they
need people to take pictures and they
want somebody who's passionate about
bowling if you love dancing they need
people who can do makeup but they want
people who are passionate about dancing
as well and you can speak both languages
that's the key I got a buddy of mine
I've used this example before named
Steve who's a financial planner like a
financial planner how many financial
planners are there out there tons but he
has a passion for hockey he loves hockey
he obsesses over it he watches it you
know as much as he can watches the same
replay 20 times he could just watch
hockey day in day out he became the
financial planner for hockey players and
so when he's talking to hockey players
now he can speak their language he can
talk about hockey he can talk about
Investments and he's one of them right A
lot of these hockey players you know the
goal in financial planning is to Target
the high net worth individuals right the
people have a lot of money those are the
people who you want to work with and so
he's able to do that by combining his
passions and so make it your own right
find a way to be able to tie whatever
other actions you have into the beauty
business and that's how you're going to
stand out I want to see more lists I
want to see your passion I want to see
your personality your character what you
believe in all of that that's got to be
real it's got to be you it's got to be
human and that connection to you and
everything that you stand for and
believe in is what's going to make me
want to come to you as opposed to
everybody else that's how you stand out
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five follow your flow
one of the most important lessons that
I've learned in business and I guess in
life is you need to follow your flow and
sometimes there are external pressures
that force you into following your flow
you may get a big media opportunity you
may get a new partnership you may get a
new a big customer that kind of
is a huge big opportunity for your
business and sometimes following your
flow I find comes from internal reasons
internal pressures maybe you wake up one
day and you really want to go try
something out or you're on a walk or
you're in the shower and a new thing
comes to your mind and and I found that
by following my flow and by following
that idea
it's always in my best interest one
because probably magic is gonna happen
if magic is going to happen it's going
to come from a source of inspiration not
just being you know doing your
day-to-day to day to day and two I
didn't want to live with regret you know
don't want to have this big list of
to-do's this big list of ideas that just
builds and builds and builds and this
Evernote file that just keeps growing I
never actually take action on stuff
right do you have an idea you want to
try something go and take action on it
huh so uh yesterday does this relates to
my book yesterday
I had a full day plan Monday is my busy
day and I record these on Tuesdays
Monday it's our my busiest day of the
week and uh I had a full day plan and
and then I just it all exploded on me
from an external Source from 50 Cent so
I made a video and 50 Cent shot and he
called it good [ __ ] and he posted on his
Facebook page and he posted it through
his Twitter account he posted a Blog
about it he kind of went crazy promoting
this and and as a result the traffic
exploded on my video comments were
coming out of everywhere people were
tweeting me they're selling it from my
newsletter they're engaging with the
video it was just insane and I had a
choice of hey I could either go with
this right or I could just do all the
work that I had planned for the day and
I chose to go with it on top of it it
was pretty cool right 50 Cent likes my
stuff and is sharing it and uh I spent a
good amount of time just with my team
just having fun in the moment looking at
the numbers seeing where it was being
shared it's kind of a big celebration
and a win for everybody on the team so
we're all kind of super pumped and
excited and I spent the day responding
to everybody and as a result got nothing
done that I was supposed to get done for
the day rule number six expect to suck
hello believe Nation I've talked a lot
about on this channel how when you're
first starting something you're going to
suck at it right any new skill that
you're trying to pick up you're going to
suck whether it's learning a language
picking up a new sport picking up a new
skill learning a video game trying to
understand marketing or accounting
whatever it is you're trying to
understand you will suck at the start
and the story I've told a couple times
on these videos is look it back on my
channel look back on my old videos and
see the progress right 2500 videos later
you can see how I've grown and I've
gotten better and I sucked at the start
and hopefully suck a little bit less now
but one thing that um that struck me as
I was watching through my channel was
the espresso series
I started that a couple months ago and
the first one that I did was of Dame
Dash
and it was a selfish project for me
because I wanted something in the
morning to kind of get me excited get me
inspired make me think bigger but when I
started it I didn't have it all planned
out and I think this is something that's
really critical for a lot of you
entrepreneurs is
you want to not over plan and expect to
suck at the start and it's okay because
you're going to get better and better
and better and better rule number seven
model the Masters I remember when I had
my first company
I really struggled at the beginning I
was making 300 bucks a month not enough
to survive I almost gave up repeatedly
and uh
was willing to try anything I felt like
I tried everything and and nothing was
working out I had a great product and I
couldn't understand why this was so hard
because the books I read and the
websites I visited
and the shows I watched everything
seemed to be so easy like follow these
eight steps and you'll be successful
well I follow those eight steps a
million times and I wasn't successful
and one of the big breakthroughs for me
came when I realized that I wasn't the
first guy to try to do this before my
first company was a software company and
I had no background in software before
apart from using you know a computer but
I wasn't a software designer
and the Breakthrough moment came when I
did realize that I'm not the first guy
to try to sell software before and I
went and I modeled
some of the largest and most successful
software companies in the world and one
in particular was Microsoft
and again I don't care how Bill Gates
makes money now but how did he go from
nothing from that idea to getting his
first customer what did he do what did
he say what were his actions what was
his what was his mindset who did he need
to connect with
and I took those strategies and applied
them to my business
and I finally started to see results
for him it was through Partnerships
so he made Partnerships he had software
he partnered with Hardware companies
his big deal came with IBM was the seven
million dollar deal that first one with
IBM that really put the company on the
map but before that he still made
Partnerships with other Hardware
companies and they sold their their
products as a bundle
and so I applied that strategy
and within the first month I closed my
first partnership deal and I made
thirteen and a half thousand dollars
now that may not seem like a lot of
money to you 13k but to me I'm making
300 bucks a month this was this was like
Eureka oh my God I struck it rich this
is amazing somebody actually believes in
what I'm doing
I'm seeing some positive momentum
finally after all this failure and
struggling
and it just kept copying that again and
I applied it again and again and again
and closed more Partnerships and more
Partnerships and continue to grow my
business and eventually
uh got acquired by someone who is a
potential partner they loved us so much
that they wanted to buy my business
and I wish I had discovered it earlier I
wish I discovered the strategy so much
earlier
because I almost shut down like I almost
quit my business and thought maybe I
should listen to my friends and go back
and get a job
and I'm so grateful that I didn't but I
came close many times to having to do
that
and so if you're struggling with your
business right now if you don't have a
lot of experience in in the field and
it's a first time thing for you you
can't get this thing off the ground
model success find someone who has done
it who's had success in your field look
at the Cosmetic lines company see how
they did it learn from their mistakes so
you don't have to make all the mistakes
yourself
and you crunch down your learning curve
so instead of it taking you years and
years and years to achieve success you
can do it a lot faster because you're
modeling things that work rule number
eight have passion that's the test you
know when you are excited by something
when you are passionate about something
when you're willing to set an alarm for
something and then wake up even before
that alarm goes off that tells you that
you're on the right path because too
many people try to plan it all out right
trying to make make it make sense up
here in your head right it's Gotta make
total logical sense before I launch and
your assumptions are always going to be
wrong and it's never going to work out
like you think it will and you spend so
much time planning that you don't spend
any time doing
and what you need to do is Follow Your
Passion even when it sounds crazy you
know I don't know how this business is
going to work out I don't know if it's
going to be with videos I don't know if
it's going to be through an agency
through tournaments through representing
players I don't know what it's going to
be but what I do know is if I don't do
anything nothing's gonna happen
and so by following my passion and by
waking up early and setting that alarm
clock and getting excited about
something
we'll explore we'll try we'll fail we'll
make mistakes and it'll get better and
we'll find our path and you need to do
the same thing too if there's something
that you are excited about something
that you want to try then start
start even if it doesn't make any sense
because by trying and making mistakes
and figuring it out you'll land on the
perfect business model to help you
explode and grow when everybody else
thought you were crazy rule number nine
impact people one of the things that I
fundamentally believe is that
entrepreneurs make the world a better
place this is we we are the people that
drive forward progress we're the people
that create the change and one of the
main reasons why I make these videos and
I'm so passionate about helping
entrepreneurs is because you guys are
the ones that's going to go out and
create that better future for for my
kids and for my grandkids and so just as
a reminder if you're struggling to I
know there's like the short-term cash
flow Crunch and you want to make money
now you're trying to figure out how to
survive and survival is important but
the way to get to becoming a successful
entrepreneur is by impacting people and
some people have a big Vision like Walt
Disney and want to create new cities and
other entrepreneurs have a smaller
vision and all you want to do is help
your local community and help your
customers who are buying from you but at
the core of every successful business is
a desire to do good and to make the
world a better place rule number 10
believe that's what drives me I wanna I
wanna have a big impact and I know I can
help people on a small scale I know I
can help you with the videos and the
videos are taking off and everything
I've done is you know it's growing
quickly but I want it to be bigger right
I want it to be life-changing on a world
scale
and I don't always believe that I can do
it because I've never done it before
because it seems like such a big goal
and I'm writing the book right now and
it's I want it to be an important book I
wanted to be one of the the top 10 most
read most valuable business books of all
time
well to say right anybody can say I want
to have this book to be the top 10 book
anybody can say that but who actually
believes that
right do I actually believe that I can
write that book
because if I don't I'm not going to
write that book
and when I'm talking to people I'm not
going to get them excited and there's a
fine line between confidence and an
arrogance or Cockiness but that's the
challenge that I'm going through right
now is believing that I can create this
amazing book and when I'm talking to
Jessica Alba and saying hey you're you
know you're a superhero in the movies
but you should be a superhero in real
life as well you could be a superhero
for entrepreneurs and and help them and
be a model for Success Through Your
Honest Company I have to do that with a
lot of confidence I have to do that
believing that this is truth rule number
11 chart your start number one is chart
your start what you do in the first 15
minutes of your day matters chart your
start have a plan of action most people
wake up like an accident most people
wake up they're tired you pull out your
phone you start looking at your email
and what are you doing when you're
looking at your email or looking at
social media you're responding to other
people's emergencies like you wake up
you're tired and the first thing you do
is you start responding to other
people's emergencies I want you to
control the first part of your day chart
your start understand what it is that
makes you come alive understand what is
the action it helps you feel bold
creative Unstoppable we've all had it
you've all had moments where you have
felt bold courageous and Unstoppable
what led to that reverse engineer
yourself what led to you feeling bold is
it watching a video is it reading a book
is it having a conversation is it doing
a meditation is it taking your dog out
for a walk is it cut in the grass like I
don't care there's no judgment I don't
care what the thing is that makes you
feel bold and courageous and Unstoppable
I just want you to do it daily I want
you to start your day with intention
most people don't start their day with
intention and that makes a difference
between the people who achieve success
and the ones who don't and so chart your
start figure out the thing that makes
you come alive that makes you feel like
that big crazy idea of yours is actually
possible and put that into the first 15
minutes of every day if you did the
thing that made you feel bold courageous
and Unstoppable in the first 15 minutes
of waking up every single day not every
day will be amazing but I guarantee you
that your life will look unrecognizable
from where you are right now chart your
start rule number 12 focus more chances
of success go up in direct proportion to
your ability to one pick the right
things to work on and then two focus on
executing those things it's so easy as
an entrepreneur get distracted we love
shiny objects right we love dreaming up
new ideas and chasing these different
projects but if you look at a typical
entrepreneur you'll see that so many of
their projects start and stop and start
and stop and you take something 10
through or 50 through or sometimes even
like 80 through but unless you're
willing to take it to 100 you're not
going to get the results you're not
going to get the fruit of your labor
because you're just planting a whole
bunch of seeds constantly but you're
never taking care of that seed you're
never watering it right if you want to
grow a plant you got to plant the seed
you got to care for the soil you got to
add nutrients you got to water it daily
it's got to have enough sunshine you got
to look after that Seed where most
entrepreneurs they don't they're
starting stopping starting to stop and
starting stopping and you never actually
get to where you want to go people talk
about diversification you need to
diversify you need to diversify and
while that's really great as an
investment strategy if you don't know
what you're investing into it's good to
have a big portfolio of different things
so that if one thing doesn't do well
something else is doing well but it
really sucks as business advice because
if you're trying to do 10 different
things at once they're all going to be
mediocre they're all going to be below
average because you're going up against
people who are doing that full-time and
have their focus on it and so it's much
better as an entrepreneur to one pick
the things that you want to focus on
right and then two actually focus on it
do that work Andrew Carnegie was once
the richest person in the world and he
had a great quote saying how he likes to
put all of his eggs in one basket and
then you watch that basket carefully
right it's only a major risk if you're
not watching the basket if you if you
take your eye off the ball you start
looking elsewhere and then something
happens to your industry right and so
being the expert being the best at what
you do will always yield more results
more value more money to you than being
okay at 20 different things be the best
at one thing Focus rule number 13 bring
Value First this is the secret to
getting ahead in business and in life
bring Value First you want somebody to
notice you bring Value First you want
someone to pay attention to you bring
Value First you want somebody to buy
from you to hook you up with a partner
to talk about you and a speech on stage
like you want people to do stuff for you
bring Value First don't go to them
asking for help first go to them with
value first so that they're stumbling
all over themselves to try to find a way
to help you out too bring value first
most people will never figure this out
most people will constantly be begging
other people be tweeting at them and
dming them and saying please help me
please help me please help and I feel so
I feel so bad I feel I feel frustrated
and I feel so bad for these people who
are just asking for help because you
know that they need help but they're
going about it all wrong by spamming
people and begging for help you're not
going to get it instead Focus your
efforts like you will never get it you
will never get it this way you're not
going to get to your outcome you're not
going to solve this problem by begging
people you'll get a little bit like even
Beggars on the street get a little bit
you'll get a little bit but you'll never
get to where you want to go
ever
by begging
instead flip it and spend your time
trying to figure out how you can bring
value to other people first so they
can't wait to help you out too rule
number 14 enjoy the process if I had to
give advice to somebody to have success
in any field not just entrepreneurship
in any field you look at the people who
have the most success in any field they
enjoy the process and too many people
are attached just to the outcome if you
want to make a blockbuster hit if you
want to make a successful movie you have
to enjoy the process of making movies as
an entrepreneur if you want to have a
successful product you want to have a
great service that's making a lot of
money you want to have a huge business
whatever you define is huge or
successful then you need to enjoy the
process of the work that you're doing on
a day-to-day basis and not ever
everything is going to be amazing you're
going to have down days but net net you
have to enjoy what you're doing you have
to wake up and look forward to the day
that is ahead and too many entrepreneurs
are spending 80 to 90 percent of their
time doing stuff that they're not good
at that they don't want to be good at
that they hate because they feel they
need to do it to grow their business and
only 10 to 20 of their time on the stuff
that they can be genius level at and you
will not have success in any Endeavor if
you're only spending 10 to 20 percent of
your time
or less on the stuff that you have the
potential to be the best in the world at
and that you enjoy if your goal is just
to make a lot of money and you'll do
whatever it takes just to make that
amount of money you'll never get there
because you don't enjoy the work
where the secret to success is enjoying
the day-to-day grind because it doesn't
feel like a grind it feels enjoyable
rule number 15 take ownership of your
life you already know what you want to
do you're letting the opinions of other
people get in the way of you taking
action people are not afraid of failing
they're afraid of failing in front of
other people you will sing all day in
the shower but you won't get on the
street corner and Shane because you're
embarrassed of the judgment and what you
need to do is inoculate yourself against
the judgment and learn to take action on
your ideas because the alternative is a
life filled with regret you have to
decide at what point are you going to
take ownership for where you are in life
like at what point do you decide my
goals my ideas my dreams my ambitions
are important enough to me that I'm
willing to risk failure I'm willing to
risk embarrassment I'm willing to risk
having to go tell my friends that it
didn't work out because this is my math
because otherwise I never get to do the
thing that I want to do
at what point are you gonna decide to
step up and say I need to do this for me
I need to know it may not work out I may
be embarrassed but I need to know I
don't want the rest of my life to sit
around wondering what if what if what if
rule number 16 work hard and smart if
you want to succeed as an entrepreneur
you need to work both hard and smart you
need both everybody who's had massive
success did both forget about trying to
work a four hour work week forget about
passive income yes you can make a little
bit yes it might be supplemental income
to help you along your journey but if
you want to do something impactful you
want to have a a big change in the world
you want to really be somebody special
and have a ripple effect out from you
you gotta do both you got to work really
hard look at whoever your heroes are
whoever it is that you look up to
they didn't get there by having things
handed to them
and they didn't get there by trying to
create passive income or work four hours
a week and I love the four hour work
week book there's a lot of principles
you can use in there except the fact
that when you are committed to something
and you love it you got to go all in on
it stop being lazy lazy people don't
change the world lazy people don't have
a huge impact I want you to have a huge
impact
and so hard work is just your ticket in
hard work alone is not the answer
there's lots of people who work really
hard
and they never rise up they never reach
their potential right you can work
really really really hard as a cashier
but if you're not thinking on a bigger
scale and you're not working smart as
well then you'll just continue to work
really really hard as a cashier and make
whatever a cashier makes and that's
where you stay
hard work does not guarantee your
success but there is no success without
hard work period it doesn't exist show
me somebody who you really look up to
and really respect who hasn't put in a
ton of effort hard work and smart work
to make it happen
and so I think if you are just looking
for shortcuts if you're just looking for
ways to make that passive income or ways
to work four hours a week and then spend
the rest of the time lying on the beach
you're being lazy and you haven't really
tapped into the thing that you love
doing because I can tell you you get
tired of lying on the beach you may not
agree because your life sucks right now
because your work sucks right now
because you're just trying to escape but
people want to do things that have
meaning
after you've escaped your life and you
spent a year on the beach you're gonna
get tired you're going to get bored
you're going to do something that fills
you up we want to contribute human
beings want to contribute we want to
feel like the work that we're doing
matters and we like to work we like to
feel like the activities that we're
filling up our day with mean something
to somebody else
so you've got to find that and when you
do you don't want to just work four
hours a week it fills you up you want to
do it a lot it doesn't mean you're
spending 24 hours a day doing it you got
to find the balance for you but when you
find the work that you love you want to
go all in on it
you want to keep going because it fills
up your soul
so you've got to work hard and you've
got to work smart it's the only way to
succeed as an entrepreneur rule number
17 get used to rejection rejection is
part of life as an entrepreneur you are
going to get rejected over and over and
over and over again it's just part of
being an entrepreneur and being a
business the first thing you put out
won't be very good people will hate on
it people give some constructive
criticism as well people will say no
because they don't know you trust you
like you and so you won't get those
first deals it takes a lot of time to
build up a business and make it
successful and even when you've gotten
to that point where you're feeling happy
and you're bringing on a team and
building the business you're still going
to get rejected constantly it's just
part of life as an entrepreneur and so
if you can't handle that it's going to
be a really hard Road for you to be an
entrepreneur I think the way to get
through ejection there's two ways to do
it one is to use rejection is fuel it's
kind of like what Jack ma did like I got
rejected 10 times by Harvard one day I'm
gonna go teach there right when they're
gonna go speak there they use that as
fuels like you turn me me down I'm gonna
show you I'm gonna beat it I'm gonna
come back and be the teacher there right
you turn me down for this deal I'm gonna
go get a deal ten times as big right so
that's one you can easily you can use
rejection as fuel to help you go off and
do something bigger and and motivation
to I'm going to prove them wrong the
second way is just to forget about it
just get used to it that's more what I
do I don't really use rejection as fuel
it doesn't really bother me when
somebody turns me down or when a new
series doesn't work I was trying to
think when I Was preparing for this
video what's the recent rejection that I
have
because there's been so many but none
really stick out as being super
memorable the one that I came up with
was I tried a new series on the weekend
a while ago about the best of
Kickstarter and it was a new series that
I was testing of showing different
Kickstarter ideas that I thought might
be helpful for you and that video didn't
do as well as I would have liked and do
as well as other videos and we're
probably gonna kill that series
but that's okay like I've killed tons of
series
it happens all the time on the channel
and I couldn't even tell you all the
series that I've killed because they
didn't perform you guys rejected them
it's okay I just moved past it and so
either one you have two strategies to go
for use the rejection as fuel to say I'm
going to show you
how wrong you are and prove it to them
or just forget about it get used to it
it's gonna happen just part of the game
and you move on and just think about the
next thing that you can go off and build
use either one of those strategies but
don't get stuck in the rejection rule
number 18 be patient most entrepreneurs
aren't patient enough most entrepreneurs
end up losing their business they end up
shutting down because they think it's
going to happen in a couple months or
even six months or a year and really
it's going to take them four years five
years before they hit their Mark they
don't have enough patience they don't
allow enough time for momentum to build
up and they quit and they end up going
back to a crappy job that they hate and
maybe never ever take a shot and get an
entrepreneurship because they feel it's
not for them or really they missed out
you missed out on your destiny you
missed on creating something amazing
because you just didn't have enough
patience now I believe in patients in
the macro I believe in patience and
knowing it's going to take a long time I
also think inpatients can serve you
greatly but that's in the micro that's
in the daily the impatience of did I do
my best today did I do my best today can
I do better can I drive more can I drive
harder and knowing that even if I give
my best every single day it's still
going to take time
it's still going to take a number of
years for something to happen I want it
to happen as soon as possible I'm going
to drive and be impatient as crazy to
get it going but I know it's going to
take time too it's embracing both that's
when you start to win I look at my my
YouTube my Instagram my social media
strategy YouTube 7
000 subscribers four years ago 1.2
million subscribers now four years by
making videos every day every day and
I'm impatient as anything because I want
it to be amazing I want to make every
video better than the last and looking
for all the hacks and SEO and thumbnail
strategies and title strategies and all
of the stuff that we're supposed to do
right I'm on top of it and I know that
it's going to take me four years to get
there I know it's going to take me a
while to get to my next 2 million five
million 10 million I look at Instagram
follow me on my Instagram Journey I'm
starting from nothing you can see how to
build it up from zero I had eight
thousand followers many of you already
have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm gonna win I'm gonna
pass people I'm gonna get mine because
I'm gonna make daily consistent content
three to four times a day for four years
I'm gonna be impatient as anything and
that the post today has to be amazing
has to be something that I want to show
my grandkids right that's the intent
every time I create anything I want my
grandkids to watch this video I want
grandkids to watch the next Instagram
thing that I put up it's the best that I
can come up with in the moment
and I know it's going to take me four
years maybe three years maybe two years
but it's not gonna take me two months
I realize it's gonna take working hard
and working smart together always rule
number 19 make no excuses successful
people don't make excuses successful
people don't complain if you look at
whoever you want to look up to look at
the most successful people in the world
in any industry look at the top and look
at how much they complain they don't
complain when you complain when you
blame something else when it's the
government's fault or interest rates
fault or the bad economies fall or your
partner who screwed you over or the
customers who don't care as long as you
can blame somebody else right the
education system your parents your
friends your upbringing there's always
somebody else to blame and when you
blame somebody else when you're in that
mindset
then you never grow you're making things
easy on yourself
it allows you to Coast it allows you to
play Live super safe because it's not
your fault that you're not more
successful of course it's not your fault
that would be difficult that would be
hard it's somebody else's fault so you
can just stay where you are because
people are holding you back from
accomplishing the thing that you want to
accomplish we're successful people
take responsibility for where they are
in life and they say I don't care about
the government I don't care who's
President I don't care about regulations
that you have or things that you're
holding me back on I will still go out
and get mine
and of course there are other factors
of course the country you come from
matters of course education you had and
and the connections you had growing up
of course it matters
but so what
you have to play the hand that you're
dealt you have these cards
you have to play those cards and you can
have success one of the things I love
looking at and this is why I do all
these profiles is a successful famous
entrepreneurs there is always somebody
who has done way more than you have done
with way fewer resources than you
already have so no matter what terrible
situation that you have and I'm
empathetic
maybe you had accounts of a broken home
maybe you have a really severe
disability that's physically holding you
back from doing some of the things you
want to do you know maybe there's a lot
of pressure on you maybe you have some
disease maybe you have zero money in
your bank account these are real
pressures and I'm empathetic to that
but so what
the longer you believe that those things
are gonna hold you where you are then
they will
there are people
who have worse conditions less money are
in worse situations and they came out of
it and accomplished amazing things
because they believed that they could
and if somebody looks like you has gone
on and accomplished big things then you
can too and it only happens when you
accept responsibility for where you are
in life rule number 20 stop using weak
language you have the power to control
your world how you think how you act
your mindset with the words that you
speak when you use weak language you
signal to yourself that you are weak you
signal to yourself that your goals
aren't important you signal to yourself
that you are not worth it you lose
respect for yourself and the people
around you don't respect you either we
need to stop using weak language and pay
attention to the words that you're
speaking to others and to yourself now
this is not an easy task because most of
the words that you're using the way that
you talk to others and to yourself
you're on autopilot you're on cruise
control it just happens you've been
doing this for years or decades and so
switching it is not going to happen
overnight but if you pay attention to
the next three things that I'm going to
share with you you can have a dramatic
impact on your self-confidence on the
goals that you have for yourself and on
the outcomes you create for yourself in
the world let's do it number one I can't
I'm not I don't what you say after those
three things shapes your identity it
speaks to how you think and speak about
yourself so I can't I can't be an
entrepreneur I can't be a leader I can't
be a YouTuber I can't I can't I can't I
can't I can't especially this one when
you say I can't pay very very very very
very very very close attention to what
follows and try and try and try to shift
it from I can't to either I choose not
to or I can't yet I'm not I'm not a good
salesperson I'm not funny I'm not the
kind of person who follows through again
pay close attention and try to shift it
to not yet I don't
I don't program I don't know how to make
money I don't think like that switch I
don't to I don't yet I can't I'm not I
don't those statements are final those
statements don't allow for growth those
statements are how you feel about
yourself and don't allow for the stretch
they don't allow you to get better and
so either eliminate them from your
vocabulary or change them to yet number
two is catch your cruise control the way
that you have been speaking about
yourself the way that you have been
talking to yourself has been happening
using the same words for years maybe
even decades it's so automatic for you
you are on cruise control you're on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control and listen don't be too
hard part on yourself this is so
ingrained these patterns have been
around for so long you are just Auto
defaulting to cruise control that most
of these times you will not even catch
it you will not catch 99 of these
moments of these words of these
languages that you're using for yourself
but if you have the awareness if you
have the intention if you have the
desire every now and then you will catch
it another quick hack is to enlist a
friend and list the people around you
your wife your husband your team your
kids kids especially my son Hayden loves
calling me out on things enlist their
help tell them this is where I want to
play a bigger game this is where I'm
frustrated with myself this is where I
keep talking badly about myself and
putting myself down these are the words
the language that need to change and
every time you hear me talking this way
I need you to bring it to my awareness
and let me know because I want to catch
my cruise control for me personally it's
around complaining anytime I complain I
want my wife I want my team I want my
son I want the people around me to say
Evan you are complaining right there
that was a complaint eat it right I'm
happy for them to hug me with it to yell
at me with it I just want them to let me
know now when I told everybody they said
let's you barely complain you're like
the least complaining person that we
know
awesome thank you I'm humbled but I
still complain and I probably complain a
lot and a lot of the times I'm missing
it and so please please please please
please please please please please
please even if you think I'm great at it
if you catch me complaining I want you
to call me out on it so enlisting your
friends can be really helpful because
you will likely not catch most of them
yourself but it's imperative that you
start working on catching your cruise
control step number three is manual
override you have caught your cruise
control you have found the autopilot
it's about to happen again this negative
talk that you're about to speak out into
the world about yourself or your ideas
you putting yourself down is about to
come out again or has just come out what
do you do about it because this is
really important if you catch yourself
playing smaller talking negatively about
yourself if you catch it
and you don't do anything it actually
makes it worse it's better that you
don't even catch it at all if you catch
it and you recognize I am playing small
right now and you ignore it and you
don't change your behavior you are
building that identity for yourself that
you are somebody who is playing small
you are consciously building that
identity for yourself and you need to
stop it it makes it worse
where when you do catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it what do you do you need to kick
your manual override into action and
take the action that you want because
that starts building the positive habit
that starts building the positive
respect this is how you build respect
for yourself this is how you start
building the muscle
this isn't just a zero-sum game this
isn't just we go back to neutral when
you catch it you either go sliding down
or you go propelling up the choice is
yours when you catch yourself playing
small when you catch yourself coming off
a cruise control
you have to do the thing that builds the
self-respect up and speak positively
about yourself and do the thing that you
are scared to do rule number 21 work the
hardest the people who win work the
hardest because they love what they do
they put in the hours and the hours and
the hours and the hours for days and
days and days and weeks and weeks and
weeks and months and months and months
years and years and years because they
love it because it's not work for them
the only way you're going to be willing
to put in the work that is necessary to
win to be the best in your industry the
only way you're going to put in that
amount of work is because you love what
you're doing
and if you don't you're gonna You're
Gonna Lose because there's gonna be
somebody who will love it who loves it
more than you and will crush you and
you'll you'll be not even a number two
you'll be mediocre because there's lots
of people who love what they do and
there's lots of people grinding it and
working hard if you are looking at your
calendar like open up your account look
what you're gonna do today or look what
you're doing tomorrow what's on the
schedule if you're looking at it and
you're like oh I gotta do all the all
these things
if that's your reaction you might be in
the wrong business now if it's a one-off
thing if it's a one day you know you got
to deal with the government or something
fine
but if that's daily if that's consistent
if that's always happening if you
continue to look at your calendar and
you're you're upset and depressed and
angry you're in the wrong business the
work
should feel like something exciting to
go and do where other people might jump
into your schedule and say that's crazy
I could never do that that's great
that's why you're not crushing it like I
am like go go crush it in your field go
do your thing rule number 22 create your
own path I think too many people are
trying to live someone else's path
you're trying to follow your parents
path you're trying to be the next
Michael Jordan or the next Wing Gretzky
or the next Steve Jobs you're trying to
be the next somebody else where if your
goal is to be the next somebody else
you're always going to fall short you
can't out Steve Steve it's not happening
it's not going to be possible so you
will always fall short if you are trying
to follow somebody else's path the key
is to create your own unique path that's
where you're going to stand out and
that's where the magic is gonna happen
you already are unique you already are
the first and only version of you that
will ever walk this planet that has
already happened but you're not the best
you yet you're the unique you you're the
first you but you're not the best you
yet and that's where you can pull from
people you can pull from jobs you can
pull from Gates and you can pull from
them free and you can pull from LeBron
you can pull from all these people to
make you the best version of you and
help you go off on your path and it
starts by understanding what your one
word is living your life on purpose
knowing what your values are and having
the self-awareness to create something
that is important and then by embracing
the genius at the end where the unique
talents that you have get mashed up
together in a way that nobody else can
execute on and it often comes by I want
to do this or I want to do this or I
want to do this and you've got two or
three or four things that you don't know
which direction to take and the real
answer is to smash all of those things
together because that's the unique thing
that only you can do anybody can be a
banker anybody can be a salsa dancer
anybody can be a gamer anybody can be a
fill in the blank but when you start
combining those things together and then
combine it with your one word which is
your value system that's something that
nobody else can do it's something nobody
else can touch now you're off creating
your own path and being the best version
of you and that's where your ultimate
success happiness wealth and impact will
come create your own path rule number 23
build self-discipline the mind is
getting in your own way if you want to
lose weight you know how to do it you
got to eat less you gotta work out more
you will lose weight why are you not
doing it self-discipline your mind is
getting in your way what I see
self-discipline as a positive I I think
self-discipline has a really negative
connotation a lot of times I think in a
lot of the messages that people are
putting out it comes across as this
really negative thing like you have to
force yourself to do all of the stuff
that you really hate and it's gonna suck
but you have to keep going you got to do
it you got to be disciplined if you're
not disciplined you suck everything's
terrible it just comes across that this
really negative forcing yourself to do
stuff that doesn't resonate with me I
see self-discipline as a really positive
thing I think it's really helpful I
think it's amazing and beautiful and
golden let's look at weight as an
example I am the lowest weight that I've
been all year I'm on a routine it's
working the specific strategies that
don't really matter one intermittent
fasting so I'll only have water and a
coffee until noon and then after that
I'll start eating I do that seven days a
week I run for 30 minutes uh usually at
night while I'm watching the show with
my wife seven days a week and then six
days a week I'll restrict my calories
not really forcing myself not to eat
food just not eating Doritos and not
eating junk right eating healthy food
six days a week and then Saturdays I get
to do what I want six days a week those
are the strategies that I use it may
seem like torture but it's not and the
thing that helps me get through it is
the mindset because the positive of all
of this is I'm losing weight I'm feeling
great I'm making progress I'm I'm super
pumped that I'm getting closer to my
goal I feel amazing about myself so I
think self-discipline usually it seems
to focus just on the actions that you
just have to grind your way through it
without enough focus on the mission of
what you're trying to accomplish and how
beautiful and wonderful that is and so
yes some of it might suck right but
you're moving towards something amazing
and beautiful so I think people just
focus too much on the negative part of
it and and if you force yourself to do
something that you hate you can only do
it for so long before you give up if you
can't tie it into the bigger picture of
what you're trying to accomplish then
you will give up and you will quit and
you will feel terrible and then I think
having other people yell at you but how
you need to have self-discipline doesn't
actually help I think it actually makes
it worse because you develop the
identity for yourself of I don't have
any self-discipline you can build it
it's not that difficult to do in my
perspective in my view all you need to
do is make sure that you have a really
strong why make sure that you have a an
outcome that you are really looking
forward to and you love doing and then
the process itself how do you make the
process as enjoyable as possible
how do you make the process just not
absolutely suck every single day going
in right if you figure that out then you
win rule number 24 don't focus on the
money if you've just focused on the
money you're never gonna get it this is
what so many entrepreneurs do and why so
many entrepreneurs fail is their number
one goal is money now money is important
if you're running a business money is
important you know even if you're
running a charity money is still
important money is important it's just
not the number one thing it's number two
or three there has to be something more
important than money for you to have
success ultimate success as an
entrepreneur sure you can make a few
bucks but if you look at the people who
are the top in any field
money was never the number one goal look
at the people who are self-made
Millionaires and billionaires and read
their biographies and read their story
and understand why they started their
companies watch the top 10 videos on all
of them it's never been about the money
it's always been about making a profound
change for the way something is done in
their industry having a deep passion for
their craft that they needed to bring
this thing out into creation you know
when George Lucas created Star Wars he
thought it would be a flop he thought it
would only be for a select few Geeks Who
really loved that genre he never
expected it to be this huge thing that
turned him into a billionaire but he
loved making the video and he poured
every ounce of creativity he had into
making that that movie and that's a
story over and over and over and over
and over again successful entrepreneurs
love their craft they want to do the
work
and as a result of creating something
valuable because they put so much love
into it then they start making money
rule number 25 start now there is no
perfect first step there is no perfect
plan there is no perfect time to get
started a lot of people are so held up
on finding what the perfect first thing
is to do that they do nothing and that's
the ultimate failure the ultimate
failure is doing nothing and just
sitting on this idea and never taking
any kind of action for it because you're
worried about making a misstep you're
worried about making a mistake you're
worried that it's not perfect your
perfectionism is killing you it's
preventing you from doing amazing things
in your life and with a business you
take any step you have a vision here's
what I want to accomplish here's my goal
I want to write the book I want to start
a company I want to whatever it is
whatever First Step comes to mind go out
and do that and then adjust adjust
adjust adjust adjust adjust adjust
adjust
you can have the best plan in the world
right and I'm all for business planning
it's not just I'm just gonna throw an
idea out there and see what happens
right you can plan you can model success
you can look at what has worked for
people
but you have to go out and do it
because the best plan is obsolete as
soon as you start executing on it and
this is what almost killed my first
business this is how I learned the
lesson because I was that guy I was the
perfectionist I didn't want to do
anything until I had it all figured out
I knew only later realized that what you
think you figured out you have no idea
what you're talking about because you
haven't gone out and done anything yet I
lost a 40 million dollar deal in my
first company I was making 300 a month
sucking in my company
turned it around started making an
income and had an opportunity to sell my
business
for 40 million dollars and I lost it to
my biggest competitor because I had to
have the perfect plan because I spent an
entire summer working on the perfect
plan and I was too late to the table I
was looking the wrong way
what made great sense on paper wasn't
actually what was going to happen in the
market and I lost a 40 million deal
because of it that kills that sucks I
was 22 years old
it's important to plan
what you need to do and don't get so
hung up on having the perfect step
don't worry what the first step is
people write in and say what's my first
it doesn't matter something do something
and then do something again tomorrow and
do something again the next day and
every day you get a little bit better
start taking massive action
that's how you're going to get that idea
out of your head finally and out into
the world so you can start reaping the
benefits and having a big impact on this
world like you are meant to do rule
number 26 find mentors I'm a big
believer in mentorship one in terms of
you know face-to-face people that you
can go and learn from and two from what
I call aspirational mentors people
who've done a lot more than you who you
may never meet who may have passed on
but you can still learn from their
success it comes from the core
understanding that whatever challenge
you have in front of you right now
somebody else has already solved it
whatever big problem you're facing in
your life or in your business somebody
has already solved it and you don't need
to come up with every ingenious solution
yourself this is one of the things that
saved my first business one of the two
most important lessons that I've ever
learned in my life was whenever I don't
know what to do whenever I have a big
problem I don't have the answer I look
for somebody who has already solved it
and I try to learn from their lessons in
my first business I had a software
company I was struggling you know making
300 a month barely able to survive and I
was just trying to come up with all
these ideas myself like okay how about
we do this how do we do this and nothing
was working
and I told my partner I quit and it was
the worst day of my life and when I woke
up the next day I realized I didn't want
to quit
I just couldn't keep going the way I was
going and the light bulb moment was I
realized I'm not the first guy to try to
sell software before maybe our specific
kind of software yes but in general
other people have figured out how to
sell software and make lots of money and
Target lots of customers
how did they do it and I looked at Bill
Gates and how he got started and how it
started the process to me be able to
build a real company and that lesson
that I learned that 19 years old has
stayed true for the past almost 20 years
where every time I don't know what to do
I look at who can I model it's why the
name of this channel is modeling the
Masters it's why I try to Showcase lots
of different successful people from all
walks of life because you can learn from
them I'm learning from them Rule Number
27 dream big it can be hard to keep
perspective when you hit a rough patch
it can be hard to stay sane and stay
motivated and stay optimistic when you
fall on tough times when something
doesn't go right when the market slows
down when you lose a big customer and
that's part of the game of being an
entrepreneur we're going to have these
highs and lows but hopefully we're
moving forward in a positive direction
and part of winning as an entrepreneur
is just sticking with it it's just
staying on the path it's just every day
getting up and being consistent and
moving forward you only really lose if
you give up right and so you can lose
little battles but if you keep going
you're going to win the war and I think
what really helps you keep consistent
and keep motivated and keep on every day
getting up and fighting
is remembering the wise remembering your
big dream the Big Goal what you're
trying to accomplish and so for me I
think about untapped potential you know
I think the biggest problem in the world
is untapped human potential I think if
we can solve that we solve all the major
problems of the world and I think the
way to help untap people or help to
unlock them help bring out that
potential is through the environment
right you may not have that with your
friends and your family your parents the
people around you
but you can get that from the books and
videos and the resources that you watch
and consume and so it's why I created
this YouTube channel like what keeps me
motivated on a daily basis is thinking
about that big problem the biggest
problem the world is facing is untapped
human potential and if I can create
content that slowly moves people forward
slowly helps unlock a little bit of
potential if you keep hearing the same
message multiple times from different
people slowly it starts to seep in right
the more time you spend around
successful people the more you want to
become successful the more you adopt
their mindset and positivity and the
more you hang around people who are not
accomplishing things who are complaining
and who are negative the more you're
going to be like those people and so my
solution is to create that for you for
myself I want to be around uber
successful people and have their mindset
seep into me rule number 28 make the
most of every opportunity you need to
hustle while you wait if you can embody
this advice and apply it to your
business on a day-to-day basis this will
be the biggest momentum shift in your
company this will move you so close to
your goals at an incredible Pace that is
unbelievable just most people don't do
it hustle while you wait listen with
every goal that you have it relies on
other people you need other people to be
a part of your process right if you're
selling to customers you need the
customer to say yes they have to make
their decision there's a bunch back and
forth if you're waiting on a product to
come you're waiting on your supplier to
come forward there's always things that
are outside your control that you're
waiting other people for and yes when it
comes to you you want to get it done as
soon as possible if a customer is asking
for a quote you want to get it off your
plate ASAP you should not be the
bottleneck in momentum happening in your
business that's a whole other problem as
soon as something comes to you it's
getting taken care of and you're
building momentum but you're still even
at the most Peak efficiency waiting for
other people
to take action that's gonna happen so
what do you do in those moments you
hustle you build new momentum you build
new clients you build new relationships
you maintain the existing ones and get
everything done as soon as possible and
then in the downtime while you're
waiting for a decision you're not just
twiddling your thumbs you're not just
sitting on the couch you're not watching
Netflix you're off hustling new business
quick example I was doing a photo shoot
with Richard this guy's celebrity
photographer he's done Lady Gaga done
the whole bunch of rappers he came over
and we did a photo shoot together and in
between his shots he's got to set up
lights he's gotta get his fog machine
going he's got to get the right angles
he's got to set up the green screen and
so when he needs me I'm there I'm ready
I'm posing I'm in action I'm ready to go
but there's a lot of setup in between
shots and so what am I doing I'm pulling
up my phone and I'm responding to you
guys I'm making videos I'm doing
responses I'm getting on Twitter on
Instagram I'm doing on Snapchat I'm
sending out video responses to you guys
I'm working I'm hustling on my down time
while I'm waiting for Rich for this
project I am hustling connecting with
you guys and that's the approach that
you need to take people say well how do
I find the time to respond to people on
social media I probably have a way
bigger accounts than you guys do and I
find the time because I make the time in
between the other things that I'm doing
this is so critical people are losing so
much time the answer is not to wake up
two hours earlier and think that's going
to solve your problem the answer is
you're losing time every single day you
are leaking valuable time from your
daily schedule and so I highly highly
highly encourage you to take this
message home while you are working while
people are waiting on you for stuff you
are doing your best to deliver as soon
as possible so that you are not the
bottleneck in your business
but then while you're away to another
people you get your hustle on you
continue to build momentum it is such a
hack to get you closer to achieving the
goals that you have for yourself stop
sleeping while you're waiting for the
people to get back to you hustle while
you wait rule number 29 always be
positive I love the idea of reframing a
negative situation into a positive one
it can really serve you it reminds me of
what Tony Robbins said of you look at
the worst thing that's ever happened to
your life and ask yourself how can this
worst thing ever be the best thing ever
how do you reframe it so that the most
negative situation ever in your life
becomes your biggest strength becomes
your mission helps you follow something
that then has a bigger impact I really
think that for people who get through a
negative situation it makes them a lot
stronger just as a human being and quite
often the mission that we have in our
lives are things that we want to
contribute and give back is so that
other people don't have to face the same
consequences the same suffering that we
faced so for me I love helping
entrepreneurs I love it it fuels me it
drives me what's the big reason for it
was because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that I want to make it
easier for other people who are like me
and if you're looking for your mission
just go back to previous pain that
you've dealt with and how you've gotten
through it quite often what you want to
do is it is then make it easier for
people to not have to suffer through the
same pain figure out what you stand for
figure out what your one word is figure
out what's at the core of you figure out
what your mission is and then any
negative situation that happens you can
reframe it to one that's empowering for
you the one that serves you the ones
that builds you up and can Inspire
others around you as well rule number 30
do not be afraid of failure if you want
to succeed then you need to adjust how
you see failure
failure is going to happen if you look
at the most successful people in the
world we've studied them they're in the
book they're all over the channel they
failed the most the most successful
person you look up to that he's like wow
that person is so successful I can't
believe it they have failed way more
than you've even tried
not everything works out most of the
series that I put out on this channel
don't work out we test constantly and
most of them never go anywhere they just
don't get enough traction there's an
experiment we failed we move on to the
next one we have failed more than most
people even try and that's why we
succeed and that's a consistent habit
around people who are winning
they win because they tried so many
other things and a certain percentage
make their way through and most people
are so afraid to fail but they don't
even try and that's the biggest failure
of all they're so afraid of it not
working out of it not being the big hit
but they just sit on their idea and then
they watch somebody else make tons of
money have a huge impact from it get it
out there it may not be the biggest
version of what you're trying to do but
start start small build momentum see if
you still even like this thing or not
see if you can get some people
interested in it or not and expect to
fail failure is not the enemy failure is
normal failure is welcomed right you're
gonna learn from it you're gonna build
on it you're gonna make it better
if you are not failing if you're winning
every time think about it like if you're
winning every time Everything You Touch
wins that means you're playing a tiny
game it means you're racing against
three-year-olds
great congratulations you won every
single race because you're running
against three Euro three-year-olds
if you want to be the best you want to
have an impact you want to make your
business a success you want to make
money you want to reach people you're
going to have to race against people
who are a little more skilled and
talented you're gonna have to risk
losing
you're not going to win every race but
the good news is you don't have to
you don't have to win every race to
succeed
you just have to win one you can run a
hundred races you just need to win one
and then they call you an overnight
success rule number 31 develop valuable
skills most of the skills that you need
to succeed are not taught in school
that's because these skills cannot be
taught from a textbook they need to be
learned by doing it they involve other
people so today I'm going to give you
the three most important skills that
I've developed that if you can get out
there and start learning will transform
your business and your life skill number
one is learn to add value if you want to
have success in business or in any
relationship you need to learn the add
value you need to learn how to
understand what the people that you're
working with what they want what their
goals are you want to be their chief
goal officer be everybody's chief goal
officer you need to understand not just
what you want but what do they want what
are they trying to accomplish how can
you bring value to them how can you help
them get through whatever problem is in
front of them right now and the more you
add value the more money you're going to
make the more Partnerships you're gonna
make the more people are going to want
to work with you talk about you be
around you because you are bringing
everybody else up skill number two is
hustle while you wait this is so
important for Success you will find this
in every single entrepreneur who has
success you hustle while you wait
there's a lot of waiting in business
there's a lot of waiting for someone to
get back to you there's a lot of waiting
for someone to sign a contract there's a
lot of waiting a lot of waiting a lot of
waiting you know on Christmas day you
might be working making videos while
other people are waiting like you're
waiting you're waiting you're waiting
you're waiting you're waiting so what do
you do while you wait you hustle you go
work on other things you start building
momentum somewhere else if you spend
your life waiting on other people and
you're not doing anything in the
meantime you will fail here's a quick
example yesterday Alex came over
yesterday was supposed to be my
mentoring day I trained Alex I work with
him I spend a couple hours with him
helping him grow trying to dance salsa
he couldn't make it in time because he
had to go to a walk-in clinic for a foot
issue great
What would most people do
most people when something gets canceled
what do you do
you go watch Netflix do you go check out
Facebook do you go consume content you
just take it as a break that's what most
people do somebody cancels on you what
do you do you take a break I deserve a
break I've been working really hard I
deserve a break
what did I do yesterday when Alex
canceled I went to work I
start getting ahead on my research I
start get ahead what I had to do today
that's the key you send something out
you're waiting for a response what are
you doing while you're waiting for a
sponsor you're hustling against 10 other
people you're growing You're Building
momentum you're planning for the future
you're doing you're grinding you're
getting out there and so that's one of
the most important skills that you can
develop while you are waiting for
somebody to get back to you while you're
waiting for yes or no or your partner to
do something you are hustling on
something else you need to learn to
hustle while you wait and skill number
three is put your goals ahead of your
convenience
guys this is important your goals will
not be convenient for you you going off
and doing that thing that is different
that is outside the norm that most
people don't have success with you want
to you have the audacity to go say I
want to be successful here you're
waiting for it to be convenient for you
they will not be convenient you will
have to do things that you are
uncomfortable with you will have to grow
in ways that you'd never imagine you
growing because you have to get outside
you have to go and Chase things that are
not going to be convenient for you and
so I look at my my tour coming up as an
example probably the most common comment
that I get from people who are learning
about the tour is when are you going to
come to my city when are you going to
come to Florida when are you going to
come to London when are you going to
come to New York when you're going to
come to my city I'm not I'm not coming
on this tour I'm not maybe I come next
year maybe I never come if you're
waiting for me to come to your city for
you to get the information you need
you're going to lose
and it's not just me it's anybody else
you're waiting for Tony Robbins to come
to your city you're waiting for somebody
else to come to your city don't
stop it you're gonna lose you have to go
out and put your goals ahead of your
convenient you're waiting for it to be
convenient for you you're waiting for it
to come to you it's not you have to go
out and claim it you have to go out and
make it happen rule number 32 love the
climb if you have to get motivated every
single day then you are in the wrong
business if you're in your business
because you thought it was a hot
opportunity or a path to make some quick
money get out immediately shut it all
down you can't sustain motivation for
that business don't start a podcast if
you don't love talking or interviewing
with people don't become an influencer
if you have nothing to say don't start a
daycare if you don't love kids it's not
worth it and you're never going to win
the work itself needs to be motivating
most days You're Gonna wake up and have
a pile of crap to deal with and if you
don't love dealing with that crap you
will get crushed by someone who does
enjoy dealing with that crap the trick
is you need to do work that you love
that other people think is crap that's
the secret so looking at my channel as
an example this YouTube channel has
grown from 7 000 followers subscribers
to 1.7 million in a matter of four and a
half years and I love the climb and I
love passing people on the way and I
love the competitive Spirit of it and I
know there's still so much room to grow
but sometimes I secretly hope that the
whole thing goes away so just so that I
could start and do it again I'm just
short of sabotaging myself although I
have taken some some risks recently if
you look at my channel last month or two
months ago I did some major changes that
did not work I bet everything on going
down the premiere Direction Just because
just because I wanted to have some
variety just because I wanted to take a
big bet and it tagged hard and it was my
worst subscriber gain in in years
and I love it
I love it I mean I don't love that I
lost but I love I love pushing I love
trying to get better I love climbing I
love trying to find a new way to be able
to go and build and get better and I
think you have to love the climb I'm I'm
just short of massively sabotaging
myself and and closing down the whole
thing just to start over but I love the
climb that much it's why I loved
Instagram I'm going hardcore Instagram
right now halfway through the year I had
six or seven or eight something like
that thousand followers and now now I'm
at almost 80 000 followers but still
posting six times a day and by going
live five times a week and by making
three to eight to twenty stories a day
and doing igtv and all that stuff I love
the climb I love it I love when people
look at my YouTube channel let's say you
have 1.7 million subscribers but you
only have 6 000 followers on Instagram
like what are you doing you're a joke I
love it I love it I love it I love
looking at everybody who's ahead and and
having the ladder to climb up again I
love it oh all the people who who I pass
on YouTube are all crushing me on
Instagram and I love it so much and it's
not doing it only to beat somebody else
it's just a competition I like the
competition I like figuring things out I
like I like the hustle and the grind to
try to win I don't like being number one
I like chasing down number one rule
number 33 take responsibility I don't
think if people take enough
responsibility for where they are in
life I think it's too easy to blame
other people it's too easy to blame your
government or blame your family for not
having the right connections or blame
your bank for not giving you the money
or you know blame your circumstances
it's too easy the thing that you need to
do the taking responsibility is painful
it's painful it's way easier to say well
I'm not successful because of this
person or this person or this person
it's not because of you no of course not
it's because of your president that's
why you're not successful and it's not
until you actually look yourself in the
mirror
and realize that there is no Cavalry
coming to save the day for you you know
there's no Fairy Godmother coming down
to Grant your every wish
it's on you and you are responsible for
where you are right now you you may not
be responsible for you know where you're
born but once you become an adult you
know you're responsible for your life
you can only blame your parents and
blame your upbringing for so long where
if you want to make a dramatic change in
your life you have the power to do it
and there's tons of people who've done
it and there's tons of people who who
started with way less look at most
successful famous entrepreneurs people
that you look up to people who think now
are living the the big life look at
where they started look at where they
came from chances are
they had way less
in terms of money in terms of Education
in terms of resources and sort of
connections than what you already have
right now the difference is their
mindset the difference is that they took
responsibility for where they're at the
difference is they said if I'm going to
get to where I need to go nobody's going
to hand it to me I need to do this
myself
and so if you look yourself in the
mirror and you're saying why am I not
successful and you're coming back with
excuses then
that's what you need to change and
recognize that as soon as you understand
that this is on you to change your life
it's on you to build your business and
nobody's coming to save you and that you
can do it once you accept responsibility
things start to change rule number 34
develop willpower willpower comes from
setting goals and keeping those
commitments to yourself when you set a
goal and you complete it you build more
willpower you are teaching yourself
you're training yourself that you are
the kind of person who sets goals and
sees them through and finishes them
which gives you greater willpower to go
off and take on bigger and bigger and
bigger goals but when you set a goal for
yourself and you don't follow through
you don't complete it you're teaching
yourself you're wiring your brain that
you're the kind of person who doesn't
have a lot of willpower you're training
yourself that you are the kind of person
who does not follow through who quits
when it gets tough so that's why it's so
important that you are very careful
about the goals that you set for
yourself because once you set a goal you
have to finish it you have to follow
through because that will change your
perspective of yourself if you finish it
and you do it willpower grows if you
don't finish it and you quit willpower
drops so here's a quick example for my
life I was driving to Boston I drove
there with with my wife with my film
team we decided to go for the weekend it
was a long drive to get the boss how
long was it Nina eight hours ten hours
how long was our Drive something like in
the eight hours it was late we got in
super late we got in at what two in the
morning one in the morning something
crazy after an entire day of me driving
I'm not sleeping in the car I'm driving
doing the whole leg myself driving the
team I arrived super late everybody's
going to bed and I had set a goal for
myself that I was gonna run for 30
minutes a day I was gonna run for 30
minutes every day that was my goal that
was my commitment to myself now
we get there it's late everybody's going
to sleep it would have been very easy
for me to go to sleep it would have been
very easy for me to let myself off the
hook and say it's okay it's late you
know I'll do it tomorrow I'll do double
tomorrow it's late it's no problem it's
very easy for the people around me to
say don't worry about it Evan like it's
late you could you could do it tomorrow
everybody will let you off the hook
when everybody else will let you off the
hook and you want to let yourself off
the hook that that moment exactly
precisely is where you develop or lose
your willpower because when it's easy
when your calendar is perfect when
there's no interruptions when you have
all the time in the world to do
something then you do it it's easy it
doesn't build your willpower you don't
feel great about yourself you if you win
a race against three-year-olds you don't
feel great you're not cheering that
Victory but when it's hard
when you don't think you can do it when
everybody's saying don't worry about it
when you feel like you're at your your
Wit's End when there's every excuse and
every reason in the world why you
shouldn't do it and then you still do it
that's when you build willpower it's
when it's difficult and you do it that
you build willpower and so I did my run
at one in the morning or whatever time
it was and it was a brutal run it was
not my best run I did not burn a lot of
calories it was not my Peak I'm I'm
tired I'm gassed I'm doing my run and
even though I didn't get a fantastic
physical benefit from it and even though
the next day I woke up and was more
tired compared to the people on my team
because I slept less
I'm giving myself pats on the back I'm
giving myself High pods like crazy I've
just built my willpower I've just built
my credibility with myself I've just
built my respect and confidence
internally because I did the thing that
I promised that I would do when it got
hard that's the difference that's how
you build willpower rule number 35 don't
care what others think I think it's
really important for entrepreneurs to
understand where your threshold is of
how much crap you could take from other
people how much negativity how much
feedback and criticism that you can take
without it impacting your psyche or your
self-worth I think in general as an
entrepreneur you need to be prepared to
get a lot of crap a lot of negativity a
lot of stuff thrown at you and yes it's
easy to say don't care what other people
think but understanding what your
tolerance level is and where you kind of
fit on that Spectrum can really help you
design the rules so that they're in your
favor so as an example this is a guy on
my team who doesn't handle criticism as
well you know I'm a lot more comfortable
in the uncomfortable where he can bounce
around a lot more he'll be on top of the
world like this is great and then a
negative feedback comes in and it really
impacts him hardly and then the positive
one comes in and he jumps back up and so
for someone like him you can't design as
much risk as much negativity or
potential negativity so you gotta take a
safe path up where for me I'm more
comfortable in the uncomfortable I know
that eventually Something's Gonna work
out and I know that at the beginning of
any project it's going to be
rough that it may not work out that
we're gonna get some criticism and so
I'm more willing to jump all in and play
in that field even though it's painful
at the moment because I know the faster
I get to that pain the faster we're
going to come out the other side I want
that feedback and criticism negativity
as soon as possible so that I can make
it better better for you better for me
better for everybody and so
understanding what your tolerance level
is of emotional stability how much you
can take from your friends and your
family and your customers and your
audience and the people watching you
before you break and then be able to
play just below that limit because you
can't just play Super safe because
that's not going to make you happy as an
entrepreneur but know what your limit is
and playing just below it so that it's
uncomfortable it's painful but you're
still going to be able to get through it
I think it's really important that
self-awareness I think is really
important as an entrepreneur rule number
36 master your craft people put too much
faith in the tools it's not about the
tools it's not about the tools that
you're using it's not about the suit
that you're wearing it's not about the
car that you're driving it's about you
at the end of the day it comes down to
you I was asked to do a Roundup of
different entrepreneurs of what your
favorite tool was to help you build your
business and they asked me and they
asked 30 other people what is the tool
that you love most that helps drive your
business forward
and I was the only one who didn't want
to give a tool everybody listed their
tools and I was at the end of the day I
was posted at the very bottom the tools
don't matter stop blaming the tools
and tools are important don't get me
wrong I love using tools I think
YouTube's a great tool I think cameras
are a great tool I use tools every
single day in my business to help spread
my message and help my company grow but
it's not the Reliance on the tools this
is where I think a lot of people fall
down I had an entrepreneur friend of
mine come to me says what tools you use
for your calendar how do you keep track
of your to-do's because she had tried
using a notebook and using Evernote and
using OneNote and using all sorts of
different tools using her phone
everything
and nothing was working it's like you
know what the problem is not the tools
the problem is you right the tools can
help you go faster but if you don't have
the mindset if you don't have the
ambition if you don't have the drive if
you're not putting in the work then the
tools will never save you and I think
people have an over Reliance on the
tools and that's my biggest problem with
it the tools can help you do that last
20 but it's 80 you it's 80 the hustle
and the hard work to get really good at
the thing and the tool can help you go
further I see tools as like pouring
gasoline on a fire
you need to have a spark you need to
have a fire to get something going and
then the tool the gasoline can help it
explode
but if you just pour gasoline on wood
nothing's going to happen I think the
same thing about suits and cars I think
a lot of people think you wear a suit
now you're going to be successful the
suit doesn't mean anything
clothing is an expression of self
[Music]
I could go in and close a sale because
they are who they are they are confident
they can close that sale where somebody
who's only deriving Confidence from
their suit will never win and so yes
tools are important but stop relying on
the tools get so darn good at the thing
that you're doing that you cannot be
ignored and then use the tools to help
you take it to the next level rule
number 37 take your shot when I was 20
years old I missed my shot because I was
scared and I vowed never to do it again
I was in Paris I was on vacation I was
in university and I'm sitting here with
my map outside your Notre Dame cathedral
in Paris and a girl comes up and asks me
for directions but she was a French girl
and it didn't twig until later that
why would a French Grill be asking me
for directions
in English
didn't really make sense right and then
I thought you know what I should ask her
out if you see what she's doing tonight
she'd take her to you know Astro for
coffee or dinner or something see what
she's up to but I was afraid I was
afraid to do it I was afraid to do it
and I let her walk away because really
was I was afraid of rejection and As
She's Walking Away the Notre Dame is on
a river and I'm on one side of the river
as she crosses over to the other side of
the river
and I was so upset at myself I was so
upset that I didn't take my shot I was
so upset that I didn't try at least try
and what I did was ended up taking a
picture
and as I took the picture she actually
walked behind one of the market stalls
and I didn't actually get her picture
it's fine so I had this beautiful
picture of this French you know
Riverside and what I did when I got home
I was still upset about it so I blew the
picture up and I put it on my wall I was
actually trying to find the picture to
show you guys but I couldn't find
anywhere in my files I blew it up though
and I put in my wall so I'm at
University I blow it up and put on my
wall everybody who walks in asked me
about the picture
and it just looks like a nice beautiful
French scene but I didn't tell anybody
what it really represented to me why it
was really so important and I looked at
that picture every day because the next
time that I had to take my shot I wanted
to go out and do it I didn't want to be
afraid I wanted to conquer my fear and
say yes
and this served me really well a year or
so later when I had to make
the really tough decision do I take this
job that I always wanted I had these
high paying job opportunities 80 to 100
000 starting salary with the companies
that I really wanted to go at or
continue with my startup that was
failing I was making 300 a month The
Logical practical safe easy thing to do
would have been to take the job it's
what I thought I always wanted so my
friends want is what you're supposed to
do coming out of University I didn't
want to live with the regret of not
knowing what happened with my business
and looking at that picture daily
reminded me to take my shot the next
time it comes around and so I gave
myself a year to say I'm going to push
off those jobs they'll still be there in
a year even if it's not those jobs it's
some other job I'm gonna give this a
shot I can deal with the failure I can
deal with the rejection I can deal with
it not working out even though that's a
really kind of short-term intense pain
when I can't deal with is there threat
of not knowing because that's not some
short-term minimal pain that's forever
if I chose not to focus on my business
and I took that job
I would forever look back on that moment
and think
what if
[Music]
what if I just tried a little bit harder
what if I gave it a little bit more yeah
you know but it wasn't working I wasn't
getting results but what if I gave it a
little bit more I did not want to live
with that regret and I'm sure you've had
moments in your life too when you didn't
take the shot when you had an
opportunity right in front of you
and you didn't go for it
like Eminem says if you had one shot one
opportunity to seize everything you ever
wanted
would you take it
and that picture on the wall helped me
take my shot
and I hope sincerely
that the next time you get your chance
at something that you don't shrink down
that you don't say no out of fear that
you don't say no because you find some
practical reason why you can't do it
that you take your shot and if you've
had those moments that you regret
where you wanted to take your shot and
you didn't
give yourself a visual reminder like I
did in my room
to say this
is not happening again
next time
I'm going to take my shot
I hope you take yours rule number 38
don't quit so I love the storm Colonel
Sanders he's one of my favorite stories
and examples to give of an older
entrepreneur this guy didn't really
start franchising his business KFC until
he was in his 60s and didn't really
become an icon or someone super well
known until he was in his 70s
how many people quit too soon on their
business I can't tell you how many
people come up to me and say Evan I'm 25
years old is it too late to get started
like what are you talking about and
really just comes down to just your
belief system here was a guy who was 62
years old when he was franchising KFC
where a lot of people would be saying
I'm getting ready to retire I'm getting
ready to slow down I'm getting ready to
wind things up you know just ease into
the rest of my life and it was a guy who
said no I'm gonna I'm gonna crush it I'm
just getting started I want to build an
Empire right and this really comes down
to whether you believe it can happen or
it can happen you're right if you
believe at 62 years old that you're too
old to get started on something new then
you're right and you won't take action
but if you believe that age is just a
number and 62 means you've got lots of
experience and you're ready to go Crush
some new project then you're right as
well and so you have to be really
careful to pay attention to the story
that you're telling yourself you because
a lot of times we're holding ourselves
back with these excuses of we're too old
we're too young we come from the wrong
country we don't have the right
education we don't have the right
parents on and on and on and as long as
you believe that reinforcing story then
it's going to continue to perpetuate now
in terms of don't quitting there's a lot
of advice saying don't quit don't quit
don't quit don't quit you should not
quit when it's your dream when this is
something that you really really really
really want to do they can't quit on it
but if it's something that you've lost
the passion for you don't feel energized
by it anymore it feels like work to show
up then that's when you quit that's when
people ask me should I quit this thing
or not well is it still your dream are
you still passionate about it are you
still excited about it because if you
are then you enjoy the process and yes
you want to get the results and yes you
want to win and yes you want to make the
money and yes you want to have that
impact but you still enjoy the process
I'd like making YouTube videos this is
fun for me it's enjoyable for me I'm
growing through it and even if I wasn't
on the path to hitting a million
subscribers I would still be doing it
because I love doing it and if I was on
the path that hitting a million
subscribers and I stopped liking it then
I would leave I would sell it I would go
do something else because you cannot do
great things when you don't love what
you do and so as long as it's still your
passion as long as it's still your dream
you have to keep going or you're going
to live the rest of your life and regret
but if you've lost that passion then get
out immediately and go do something else
that does bring you excitement Joy
energy and
rule number 39 act despite fear fear is
normal as part of what makes you human
you would not be human or you'd have
some crazy condition if you never felt
fear I think the people who say Don't Be
Afraid aren't giving you practical
advice it's be afraid feel the fear and
then step into it and do it anyway and
the more you get used to taking on those
fearful projects that you're scared of
the stronger you'll get the more
resistance you'll get the higher
tolerance you'll get to do bigger better
Bolder better things I think the trick
though is spotting the fear
here's what I think happens to most
people there's some opportunity that
comes along
there's some moment that comes along
whether it's with a client or meeting
somebody or an event something comes
along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it it's going to stretch
you beyond what you've ever done before
and then what you do is you rationalize
saying no
I don't have the money to go to that
event
I'm too busy to go and do that thing
right now you find the reason why you
can't go and do it you rationalize it
but really deep down the reason is
you're just afraid and until you spot
the fear until you understand that it's
really just the fear then you're never
going to solve the problem
so step one is understanding
when there is fear
step two is then stepping into it and
doing it anyway and a lot of this stuff
is just so subconscious you know we as
human beings are kind of trained to when
we're afraid something's going to go
wrong and to be safe and so it's trying
to catch that subconscious action and
proactively change it so an example for
me when I was starting my YouTube
channel
my agent would tell me you have to go
and do videos in public I want you to go
out on the street and make your video in
public
my natural reaction
was
fear but I didn't catch it initially it
was
the gear won't be as good in public you
know I can't control the light settings
I'm going to be bouncing around with the
camera it's not going to be a great
experience for the people watching why
would I do that I'm rationalizing a
reason why I don't have to do it or
really I'm just afraid right you could
solve all those problems and he told me
stop being afraid and just go out and do
it he cut through it and let me see my
own fear
and so I did it and when I first went
out and filmed in public I took out it
was my phone or my camera I don't
remember and I'm walking down the street
and then the postman is there so as soon
as I see the postman
I quiet down and I can put the camera
away
just walking normally
and then when the postman leaves
I'm back to filming
and that time I noticed like I'm I'm
doing it because
I'm afraid and I got pissed okay next
time
I gotta speak up next time I gotta do
better and so I went out
and force myself to go and do it again
and I was walking past and there were
these construction workers and instantly
again the the Panic set saying like
people are watching the construction
workers like I know they don't really
even care about me and what I'm saying
what's happening on the street
but I forced myself through it it was
awkward it wasn't great I think I had to
redo it again anyway but I I took the
step
I got better at it I recognized the fear
and I jumped into it and now it's to the
point where I'll make videos walking on
the hall and make videos when I'm at
Disneyland Disney World you know I'll
make videos in the streets of anywhere
and there's still a moment even now
after how many videos I've done there's
still a moment of who's watching
I think it's natural normal it's not as
strong as it used to be and more
importantly it doesn't limit me from
doing the thing that I want to do
and so spotting the fear
and not rationalizing it away and not
just doing what your subconscious always
does that keeps you down where you are
is so important
being truthful that the reason why you
said no
or you're not taking this opportunity is
just because you're afraid and the
answer to saying no should never be
because I'm afraid
you want to re-jig your system so
whenever that's the answer because I'm
afraid to do it now you have to do it
rule number 40 serve others if you are
not happy in life it's because you're
not serving enough I believe that humans
are good
99.99 of humans are good there's a tiny
little fraction of a percent of people
who enjoy giving harm and hurting others
because they have some chemical
imbalance but apart from that people are
good and we are connected to each other
your highest purpose in life will come
from helping others but the next
question becomes how how do I do it how
do I find my higher purpose how do I
know what I'm supposed to do how do I
get direction I'm going to give you the
three-step process that I call the
purpose planner that will give you the
clarity that you're looking for I break
it down into your who your why and your
how let's start with the who your who is
your one word most important core value
everybody has a core value if you're a
human being you have a core value that
you believe in more than anything else
and when you understand who you are when
you understand your single most
important core value then you're less
likely to be swayed by other people
you're less likely to live somebody
else's version of your life because they
have Clarity and you don't when you do
not have Clarity you end up chasing
everybody else's Clarity you end up
doing their version because they have
certainty and you have no idea what
you're doing it's like you're walking on
quicksand and you're constantly sinking
and you know this is something greater
for you your one word your most
important core value is the rock that
you stand on when the rest of the world
is crumbling around you so for me it's
belief my one word is belief that's what
I stand on if you love believe you're
going to be a huge fan of this channel
because I talk about it in some form in
every video every video should ooze
believe if you hate believe you're
probably gone by now you hate my channel
and that's okay go go do your thing
somewhere else you need to figure out
your who you need to figure out what
your one word most important core value
is that becomes the lens through which
you see your entire world and attracts
the goodness into your life step number
two is your why why do you do what you
do now I'm a big believer that your
purpose comes from your pain that
whatever your most painful moment was in
life whatever you struggled with the
most growing up in life whatever moment
in life you felt the most worthless as a
human being
your highest purpose your greatest joy
and satisfaction will come from helping
people who are currently feeling the way
that you felt who are currently facing
that situation that you were in that you
hated the thing that you would never
wish upon anybody else in the world lots
of people are going through that thing
and if you can step in and help those
people that's going to be so filling up
your soul I can't even explain it to you
for me my one word is believe that's my
who my why is I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur I hated my life I was
struggling with making 300 a month I
felt worthless as a human I felt like I
was bringing no value to the world and
that was massively frustrating I felt
alone and I didn't know what to do
that's why I love helping entrepreneurs
I love believing in entrepreneurs why
entrepreneurs could be anybody I could
believe in anybody believe is at the
core of who I am it's my one word most
important core value but I could be
believe it in anybody and I do and I
love it but entrepreneurs hold that
special spot for me and the startup
entrepreneurs not the ones who are
already making tons of money I love them
too but I resonate made so much more
with the startup entrepreneurs because I
remember what it's like eating at
McDonald's and only being able to afford
french fries instead of an entire meal
so your why your purpose comes from your
pain figure out what that most painful
moment was for you and it's hard because
entrepreneurs we like looking and being
optimistic and looking forward and being
positive but it's in that pain that your
answer actually is find out what that
most painful moment was your why your
highest purpose will come from helping
people who are currently facing that
right now and then step three is the how
so how are you going to do it there's a
lot of ways you can help people who are
in that situation so for me you break it
down the who is my one word is believe
the wise helping entrepreneurs purpose
comes from my pain the how do I help
entrepreneurs how do I believe in
entrepreneurs is that there's a ton of
ways that I could be believing in
entrepreneurs so the example I use of is
if you are moving your office and you
need my help to rent a moving truck and
to help you carry your desks and all of
that stuff I love the end result of it I
love that now you have this great office
where you can build a business and have
it flourish and I'll probably say yes to
helping you do that especially if you're
a close friend
but I don't love the process of moving
I don't love the process of packing up
boxes I don't love the process of
setting up cables and wires and putting
together an office I don't love that
process I love the result because I'm
believing in entrepreneurs but I don't
know the process and so if you write
down you make a list of all the things
that you do the activities that you have
done that you've enjoyed the result make
a list of 10 to 15 times you've helped
somebody with that same pain that you
had growing up
you've helped them and you enjoyed the
end result and then Circle the wines
where you enjoyed the process as well
because when you can enjoy the process
and you enjoy the end result it's a home
run now you've found your higher purpose
now you have clarity now you have a plan
that's the point of the purpose planner
step one you figure out your who your
one word most important core value step
two you figure out your why your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
never want anybody to ever have to
experience again because it was so
painful for you and then step three is
the how the process you need to love the
process you figure out those three
things you are set for life rule number
41 take ownership of your life if you
woke up and did the thing that made you
feel bold and Unstoppable and powerful
and confident every single day if you
started your day with that thing your
life would look dramatically different
one year from today compared to where
you currently are right now the problem
is most people wake up like an accident
most people they wake up they check
their phone and they're immediately
responding to other people's emergencies
and demands on your time you're not in
control you haven't decided to take
control of your day that your day is
important that your life is important
and you are going to take ownership of
it and so you need to block off the time
in the morning and maybe five minutes
maybe you need 15 maybe you need an hour
and a half whatever it is the thing that
makes you feel bold Unstoppable powerful
confident fill your cup every single day
because other people have demanded your
time and they won't fill your cup for
you you have to say this is my ownership
right here nobody's touching it I'm
taking charge now that looks different
for different people how Oprah does it
is different than how I do it is
different than how Dwayne The Rock
Johnson does it Dwayne Johnson has to
get his four hours of workout in every
day when he's working on a movie set and
he has to be in by nine he'll wake up at
four in the mornings he can go work out
for four hours and then go back and and
shower and get ready for his movie so
he's only sleeping five hours a day when
he's doing movies I think that's crazy
but to him that's balance that's him
filling his cup that's him reminding
himself of what he's doing he loves
working out
that's why I don't look like doing The
Rock Johnson right there's a difference
between us I would rather sleep I would
rather do something else in the morning
and so we tend to look at what we're
doing against somebody else you tend to
look at Oprah and say well she's doing
it this way I need to do that Dwayne's
doing it this way I need to do that
Evan's doing it this way I need to do
that you judge yourself against other
people's routines and methods of filling
their cup and I think that's actually a
recipe for failure because you are not
that person because what works for them
is not going to be the exact same thing
that works for you here's the good news
you already know what fills your cup you
already know what makes you feel bold
and alive and full of momentum and
confidence you have had that happen to
you in the past you're just not living
there consistently you know what has
helped you feel full
but you're living there one percent of
the time and 99 of the time you spend
reacting to other people their demands
their emergencies their issues for your
time and so reverse engineer for
yourself when was the last time you felt
filled up motivated confident bold
excited what happened what were you
doing what led to that thing to happen
were you watching a video were you
listened to a podcast where you're
reading the book we're going to an event
a seminar where you're outside you know
I'm sitting here on a swing here outside
where you're outside you need to get out
of nature do you need to meditate you
need to have a shower do you need to
dance to music like what's the thing
without judgment without caring if
anybody else has to do that thing maybe
you need to wake up every day and pet
your frog and that's the thing that
makes you feel amazing great do that
plan for it every single morning because
I guarantee you if you did the thing
that helped fill your cup that made you
feel bold and Unstoppable and confident
and Powerful if all you did was wake up
every day and did that thing
your life will be dramatically different
one year from today compared to where
you are right now you will not recognize
your life so please stop waking up like
an accident and put this into your
morning routine every single day rule
number 42 find your purpose finding your
purpose guys is not that difficult
it's not that difficult it's one of the
most common questions that I get
[Music]
I get the time in your life for you felt
the most worthless think about the time
the lowest slow that you've ever
experienced in your life what was that
moment your purpose now where you will
get the most fulfilled of all time will
be helping people who are currently
going through the thing that you went
through
that's it think about the most painful
moments of your life the thing that you
would never want to experience ever
again think about the thing you would
never wish upon your worst enemy
definitely not your friends your family
your kids
think about that moment
your greatest purpose your greatest
enjoyment your greatest fulfillment in
life will come from helping people who
are currently facing that thing that you
faced
that is your purpose for life it will
never get old helping those people will
never get tiring rule number 43 grow and
improve self-improvement is the answer
to whatever obstacle is staring you in
the face right now the only difference
between you and greatness is the
willingness to grow and improve it's not
Talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and Tony Robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who had 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like Jim Rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over six billion dollars
in annual revenue if Tony Robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
College education to being one of the
most influential people in the world
why can't you the difference is he made
the investment to constantly improve
himself and you haven't yet at that
level so I look at my channel as an
example my YouTube channel and I've
learned so much over the past number of
years in confidence and growth and
abilities and skills by consuming the
content because I love the top 10 Series
in the meant to me Series in the
instructional series I make them for me
and then I share them with you and
thankfully you guys like them too and I
can build a business off of it and keep
pumping out more content but it helps me
I've grown I've learned and one of the
biggest moments that helped me realize
how much I've learned is when I signed a
three-year deal with sage I was working
with Stephen Kelly who was the CEO and
every month we'd be on a call we'd be
doing a hangout on my YouTube channel
answering questions from people and I
was driving with my dad and I remember
him asking me how do you get the
confidence to be on a call with Stephen
Kelly and be seen as his equal all the
time and he wasn't asking me to put me
down he was asking me in genuine of he
was so happy for me that I was playing a
bigger game and it dawned on me that he
was right
the Evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the Evan of five
years ago would have felt less than the
Advent of five years ago would have said
there's no way I'm capable of doing that
and then when I'd signed the deal I felt
like
it's great I love Stephen he's amazing
but I feel like I'm hanging out with
Oprah and Kanye and Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates and these super successful people
and they're infiltrating my brain on a
daily basis right a daily basis three
videos every single day on this channel
and so bit by bit it pulls me up now I
recognize I still have a long way to go
I still have so much more to learn I
still need to believe in myself even
more and every time I consume more
content it allows me to grow my comfort
zone a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit more and the funny
thing is all of these moments are are
little tiny incremental parts of your
growth I couldn't point you to one point
in my past where I said that was the
moment that I changed that was the
moment that I had more confidence but as
I studied every day every day every day
I could look back three months six
months a year and say wow I've really
changed I've really grown I really
learned a lot but in the daily from
today to yesterday I'd say I didn't grow
it all and so sometimes I'm your
Journeys you're trying to learn and get
better you may feel like the growth is
really slow on a daily basis but if you
keep going you keep investing you keep
learning you keep seeking out mentors
you keep trying to get better and
improve not every day will be amazing
but if you try every day to get better
and learn I can guarantee you that in
three months six months one year when
you look back of the person you've
become compared to what you are right
now there'll be a big change and that's
because you continue to invest in
yourself rule number 44 start small I
hate spending money till I'm making
money if you do not have money it's
because you are spending your money on
things that are not making you money
this is what happens in so many
entrepreneurs businesses when you're
starting you go and you spend a whole
bunch of money on different gear
equipment samples products and then it
doesn't work out
instead of going out and spending money
at the start find a way to get started
on the cheap invest in your energy your
hustle your drive your initiative but
not your money here's what happens
someone wants to start a teacher
business okay great
to get the price discounts that you want
so that on a per t-shirt basis it's
cheaper you have to order 5 000 t-shirts
so you go out and you spend all your
money ordering 5 000 t-shirts or worse
you go take a loan
so you can get your five thousand
t-shirts the t-shirts come in you sell
three of them and then you have four
thousand nine hundred and ninety seven
t-shirts sitting in your mom's basement
that's most people you'll spend money
because you've got this ambitious dream
and vision you see in your head how it's
all going to work out but then when you
get started it never works out like you
think it's going to work out when I
first started on YouTube
I had a team of eight or so people
already in my other business in my main
business and so I'm going to try this
thing on the side just as a fun thing
and see how it goes I did everything
myself myself I did everything myself I
invest my energy my heart my hustle my
drive my intuition into making something
happen and once I started making
somebody then I could invest into
building a team into getting gear into
building this business up so now we've
got 24 people on the team when I first
started doing my Instagram live morning
shows it was me and my tripod and a cell
phone and a guest and we went live on
Instagram every day and then people said
hey you should get a microphone okay
great I got a quick little microphone
that connected and we went now this
thing might be the future that may be
all I do I might even close down YouTube
and just do Instagram lives and if that
happens then I'll invest in a team and
making that happen maybe in three years
if I'm still doing it there'll be 20
people in the room from a producer and
Camera people and editors and
everybody's in the room guiding the show
right that might be the future
but I don't know I gotta start by just
doing one show
you do not have money because you're
spending your money on the things that
are not working and generating money
back for you so stop spending money stop
it stop it right now stop spending money
on things that don't make you money
instead invest your energy your hustle
your time your drive as a default until
you're making a little bit of money from
that thing a little bit of money from
that thing
and then you can invest that money to
make more money rule number 45 love the
process if you are thinking about how
many hours you're working and you're
frustrated and you're complaining I
think you've lost like I think if you
are counting down as an entrepreneur how
many more hours go until the day is over
until you get to go on your vacation
until you know the weekend is here I
think you've lost like I genuinely think
you've lost you have to love the work if
you look at
look at all of the people that have done
profiles on across entrepreneurship
Athletics singing everybody they love
the work you have to love the process
not just the results it's why you have
to love it so much to put through all
the crap all the negativity all the
burnout all of the stuff that happens to
you as an entrepreneur you have to deal
with it and the only thing that gets you
through
is you love it I'm making videos I'm
here in Albuquerque Nina's getting her
nails done Danny's getting his phone
charged in the car and I'm making videos
because I love making videos because I
can't wait to make videos videos I've
done six thousand plus videos on my
channel and I can't wait to make more I
love it I love the process I love
helping entrepreneurs I love the results
and I love the process and yes that can
cause personal issues that can cause
Health breakdowns that can cause you to
get stressed out that can cause you to
push beyond your limits that can cause
you health issues it can relationship
issues it can and it does for so many
entrepreneurs and yes you need to guard
for that you need to watch for that you
need to be able to create an intentional
life not just working working working
working all the time and then you die
but you need to love the work you need
to love the process it's not painful to
do it saying pay the price it's not
painful to pay the price for you
stepping into my schedule making 6 000
videos you might think is really painful
for me it's not like I love it it's
great it's amazing and that should be
the same thing in your business people
who say and say well do whatever it
takes no you won't
do whatever it takes
because as soon as it starts getting
really hard you're gonna quit or
somebody who actually loves that thing
will keep going because they love it and
you don't and whenever you're up against
somebody who loves to work and you don't
they will destroy you even if you have
more natural Talent they will destroy
you because they love the work and you
don't it makes all the difference in the
world rule number 46 stop complaining
your entire life changes when you decide
to take responsibility for where you're
at for it for your happiness for your
success for where you're at in life when
you decide that I am responsible
Everything Changes we don't want to
because it's easier to blame somebody
else it's easier to blame somebody else
we don't want to blame the person in the
mirror we don't blame ourselves it's
somebody else's fault right it's Nina's
fault that I'm not happy where are you
Nina
blend yourself
it's Nina's fault that I'm not happy
right it's so good to put the blame on
somebody else because that means I don't
have to do anything but when you take
the personal responsibility when I say
it's my fault that I'm not happy it's my
fault that I'm not more successful it's
not my team's fault that my company's
not blowing up as big as I wanted to
it's my fault I need to get better it's
not my trainer's fault that I'm not
getting results in the gym it's my fault
right I gotta eat better I gotta work
out more it's my fault it's your fault
you are where you are because of you and
when you accept that then you choose to
now live a life of being able to make
progress most people don't want to do
that most people would rather consume
entertainment instead of Education
most people would rather consume
entertainment and sit down and watch
Netflix and forget about their crappy
life than try to fix it most channels on
YouTube that blow up are not education
related they're entertainment because
people want to shut off their life shut
off their brain and just be entertained
instead of trying to actually fix the
problem if you're a subscriber here
you're probably on education side but
are you the kind of person who's going
to take responsibility and fix your life
or just shut up the world blame complain
wait till you can't have that next
vacation you can't wait till that next
weekend in the evenings are coming up
because your life sucks your life sucks
is it your fault or somebody else's when
you think ownership that's when life
starts to change rule number 47 surround
yourself with success the fastest way to
grow is to be around people who are
doing what you want to do period when
you are around people who are building
and growing and taking on the world and
trying to accomplish their dreams and
you're in that environment and you're
learning even just being around them
it's gonna seep into you and get you
more motivated and pumped up and fired
up to go off and chase your dreams most
people have a pretty crappy environment
most people if you're an entrepreneur
most people they don't have a bunch of
entrepreneurs in their family most
people when they tell their family and
their friends what they're doing they
think they're crazy they think that you
shouldn't go off and do that thing you
should go and get a safe normal typical
job a lot of people have a lot of
negativity around them if you are
constantly surrounded by negative people
people bringing you down it's really
hard to be the one person trying to go
off and make a huge difference and so
that's you if that's your situation then
you need to change your environment you
need to be surrounded by people who are
like-minded who are off chasing their
goals and you need to find some mentors
let me give you some quick tips on how
to do it because if you don't you're
never going to get to where you want to
go you won't staying right now where you
are needs to be unacceptable needs to be
unacceptable because you will never get
to the spot that you want to be at if
you stay exactly where you are with the
people in the environment that you have
around you step number one is limit the
exposure to negativity that means you
mean you cut off some friends just
because you were friends in elementary
school doesn't mean you should still be
friends now it doesn't doesn't mean you
have to be rude to them you've just
Grown Apart it's okay
it's okay it's great
you'll get new friends we need to limit
exposure to negative toxic people if
those are your parents you may not want
to completely eliminate them from your
life although for some people that's an
important step it may just mean cutting
off exposure to some topics if you know
that your friends or your parents talk
to them about your business ideas is
always going to lead to a fight
negativity just don't talk about it say
I don't want to talk about that and find
something positive that you can relate
to and talk about step one you have to
eliminate the negativity or limit
exposure to it in your life you will not
do great things if you are constantly
bombarded by negativity step number two
now you have to fill the void you got to
fill the void with positivity and so
that's reaching out that's joining
communities that's going to events
that's going to groups I'm on my tool
right now I'm in Albuquerque New Mexico
I'm doing an event tonight here in
Albuquerque and when people come
together who are like-minded all the
people who come to my events they're all
entrepreneurs and they all want to go
off and do something amazing and for a
lot of the people coming out they're the
only ones that they know who are off
trying to to do something and now they
meet local people who are also similarly
minded you need to be around similarly
minded people and so check your local
city check your local groups see what's
happening see what's coming up get
involved get out of the house stop being
in your regular routine your your
current environment is not helping you
you need to get out and meet new people
and you may go to an event and meet only
one person that is potentially
like-minded amazing collect people I
like collecting good people collect them
I'll even be super awkward about it
almost intentionally where if I really
like somebody and we have a great
conversation
say you know what I really like you
um that sounds weird I'd like to find a
way to spend more time together like
maybe we meet up once a month for a
coffee and just talk about business
that's how you do it you just ask and if
you had that with four or five different
people then every week you're meeting
somebody on a regular basis who fills
you with positivity and energy and so
you have to go off and find those people
you have to say yes and go to those
events to meet to be around the positive
energy because what makes such a big
difference if you accomplishing your big
goals and then step number three is get
more mentors you need to get mentors and
one are aspirational mentors and that's
what I see through what I do right
through my content I learn through the
aspirational mentors I learned from
Kanye I learned from that and upon me I
learned from Oprah Winfrey I learned
from Mel Robbins I learn from these
people they make me better even though I
haven't met most of the people that I
profiled on my channel I learn from them
they make me better being around them
and their energy and their wisdom gets
me fired up seeing people going up doing
amazing things and I get that three
times a day on my channel right like it
will shift you it will if you are
watching content you may never meet
dandapani but if you're watching his
content if he inspires you and you watch
his content on a daily
it will shift you because now he's a
voice of positivity in your life and
then you can get real mentors as well
for those of you who are following my
path to 10 million subscribers series
I'm having people who I respect and look
up to coach me on different things and I
need to get better at who they'll watch
my stuff and say hey here this is where
you're great but here you suck you got
to get better at this thing you need to
make the decision to change your
environment you need to make the
decision that your life is important
that your mission is important that
being where you are right now is not
acceptable that you don't want to be
here again in a year like one year from
today you can't be in the same
environment you can't be around
negativity and toxicity every single day
you need to follow those steps you need
to remove the negativity from your life
you need to seek out positive energy and
be around people who build and lift you
up and you need to start seeking out
mentors whether they are face-to-face
mentors or aspirational mentors to help
you get to where you go your life is
important your mission is important you
need to start treating it as so rule
number 48 change your mindset you're
never going to accomplish anything great
if you're coming from a place of
negativity if you're just complaining
and negative and blaming other people
you're never going to accomplish
anything it's just not gonna happen you
can't create amazing things from a
negative spot it means that you have
zero resourcefulness because there's no
hope and so you need to flip it now I'm
going to give you a wild mind trick that
that I use that maybe is a little too
weird duck for you but I want to sit on
you because if if one of you picks it up
it'll dramatically change your life it's
my philosophy of changing negative
situations and doing a quick Mind Trick
In My Head to say it's the best so
whenever I'm hit with a negative
situation something that is beyond my
control something that I can't do
anything about I will complain I will be
unhappy I will be negative for 8 to 24
seconds
and then I'll tell myself
it's the best that this is the best
thing that happened to me and then I'll
figure out why it's the best so as an
example I'm on an airplane I'm coming
from Vancouver to La I'm speaking at an
event in La I'm on a flight it's a five
hour flight I get on this is really
smelly dude next to me really smelly guy
I he probably hadn't been on you know in
a shower in a couple days probably had
multiple transfers and stopovers and I
have empathy I'm not I'm not pissed at
him I'm pissed at the situation right
I'm sure he's normally a nice smelling
guy and uh takes care of himself but in
this situation
he was super smelly and I had to deal
with it so what am I gonna do I got a
five hour flight what are my options I
can not go you know I could miss my
flight and then not do my presentation I
could sit on the airplane and be upset
for the next five hours and then be
upset for the rest of the day and allow
this minor situation to own me and to be
better than me and ruin my entire day or
I could say this is the best
and that's what I did for around 8 to 24
seconds I'm sitting there trying to
figure out my options what options do I
have how can I do how can I fix this
there's no options I'm screwed and then
I'm upset you know I'm upset this sucks
come on really this is what I have to
deal with for the next five hours and
then this is the best and what do I do
[Music]
yep Breathe It In Breathe It in give it
to me because this is making me stronger
this is the best this is actually the
best why because it's my chance to show
myself what I'm made of that this smelly
dude is not gonna own me that I am
stronger than a little bit of smell on
an airplane and that the next time I get
faced with a similar situation I'm able
to handle it it's easy it rubs off me I
think that's how you actually build
self-confidence that's how you actually
build self-esteem because when it's easy
it's easy winning a race against
three-year-olds is easy doesn't mean
anything you're not going to clap that
up yeah I beat a bunch of
three-year-olds but when it's hard and
you try that's when you actually build
self-esteem and so flipping flip it in
your mind flip it this is the best
whatever negative situation is in front
of you right now tell yourself it's the
best rule number 49 get attention people
often ask me what is your business model
11 how do you make money this is it this
is my business model I kick up as much
noise in my industry I get as much
attention as possible in my industry and
then I find ways to monetize it that's
it when you have a lot of attention in
your industry people will find you and
throw opportunities at you my biggest
challenge is trying to figure out now
which opportunity to go after I get
speaking gigs because of the attention I
built on my YouTube channel I get
opportunities to connect with people
like Tony Roberts and have them be
interviewed on my channel I get brand
deals with people want to partner with
me I get book deals everything has come
because of my YouTube channel because I
built up a quarter of a billion views
because I have one point whatever
million subscribers I just pick up a lot
of attention in my industry and then
deals come to me and that works really
well for someone like me because I'm
introverted because I'm much better at
marketing than I am at sales and so
instead of me spending time which would
be more wasted time going out trying to
connect with people trying to reach
people because I'm introverted I just
get to work on creating amazing content
and I have people then find me and find
me out the places and pay me to do
things because I built up the marketing
attention machine and rule number 50 the
last one before very special bonus clip
is have a mission when you have a
mission you're not for sale
when you know what you're doing when you
have a deep purpose and you are off
chasing it you are not for sale money is
really important but if you look at the
successful people look at anybody you
look up to who you respect who's your
hero who's your hero who's your greatest
most famous entrepreneur of all time
that you love and you would love to
emulate money was not the most important
thing to them there was something above
money now money is important money is
important for every business money is
important for every organization if
you're a charity money is still
important but it's not number one
and you got to figure out what you would
put ahead of your money so many people
are just chasing money money money money
money and I get it it's important I had
I had a woman who was at my seminar last
night here in Indianapolis who she has
eight different side hustles and now
she's trying to get into real estate to
try to make money and the problem is
none of it's Purpose Driven and none of
it is actually making her enough money
she's making just enough just little
tiny bits from these side hustles that
she can barely survive
it's a wrong path the people who only
prioritize money never make money they
never make the real money you make just
enough to survive because your will to
win is for sale
you've got to figure out what your
purpose is you got to figure out who you
are you got to figure out what the
mission is that you're on when you do
that
then no matter how much money is being
thrown at you
you're not going to accept
because you're on a deep purpose for
life
now I've got a special bonus clip on how
to strive for excellence that I really
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
Landing question let's go from just
watching another video to taking action
here we go question number one what can
you just start small on today number two
where do you need to act despite fear
and number three how can you bring other
people value first life isn't fair
the family you're born into the country
you're born into your religion your skin
color your gender there's a lot of very
real things that exist in this world a
lot of very real prejudices that hold
people back life isn't fair and chances
are you might not have the capital or
the education or the resources or the
parents or the family or the connections
or the right skin color or the right
gender or any of these things you might
not have at all lined up for you
perfectly and so the next step is then
what do you respond to
so yes you're right and then what
are you gonna be like what most people
do is they just complain they complain
that life isn't fair they complain that
they don't have the right circumstances
and then they become a victim of those
circumstances or are you going to take
the more difficult path the one of
taking personal responsibility personal
accountability and choosing excellence
and saying I'm gonna break free of this
mold I'm gonna break free of the
circumstances that were placed above me
I'm gonna set my own path I'm Gonna Make
the World better for myself and the
people around me I'm gonna choose
Excellence if you look at the people
that you love the people you look up to
the people that I profiled in this
channel whoever your heroes are Your
Role Models the people you aspire to be
chances are they came from nothing
chances are they had tons of odds
stacked against them and they chose
excellence and that's why they won look
at Michelle Obama her father was an
employee at a city water plant her
mother was a secretary and then once she
had kids was a stay-at-home mom so
Michelle Obama is the daughter of a city
water plant employee and secretary
turned stay-at-home mom and chances are
again whoever you look up to they have a
similar story it's very very very rare
and I've covered lots of these people I
may have covered more than anybody
online I've covered lots of successful
people it's very very very rare
that the son or daughter of a great
person goes on to do great things
themselves it's very rare that the kids
of people who've done amazing things go
on to do amazing things themselves it's
very rare it doesn't happen that often
and you might think that sounds crazy
these kids of super successful people
have everything lined up for them have
the money the education the resources
all the time in the world everything
handed them on silver platter it's so
easy for them to win
and that's why they don't win because
you win through the struggle because you
win by overcoming the Yachts because
that's how you develop Excellence by
going after the difficult things the
people who have an easy life never win
the people who have a hard life and
overcome and choose excellence and drive
daily and refuse to be a victim of those
circumstances those are the people who
ultimately win and so that's you right
now if you've you feel like the world is
unfair first of all you're right and
second there's a there's a bunch of
things that are stacked against you
then I would highly highly highly
encourage you
to surround yourself with the stories of
people who have made it with the stories
of people who look like you who have the
same background as you who have the same
circumstances as you who made it because
if they could make it then you can too
and most of the people that I profiled
most of the people have done videos on
this channel look at their stories
chances are they came from a worse
upbringing than what you have right now
they had less than what you have right
now when they started and one of my
favorite stories is Oprah Winfrey and
she was so poor growing up you know she
grew up without parents she grew up
being abused by her family she grew up
with her grandmother who had no money
and put together dresses made out of
potato bags can you imagine going to
school in a potato bag that was sewn
into a dress like how the ridicule would
be from your classmates at school
wearing a potato bag as a dress to
school can you imagine that and look
what Oprah went on to do
are you gonna tell me that you have a
worse upbringing than what Oprah had
or any of your Heroes
spend the time don't look at how
Michelle Obama or Oprah win for any of
these people make an extra million
dollars right now spend the time to look
at their backstory spend the time to
understand where they came from and when
they chose excellence and how it had a
massive difference and change of
trajectory of their life
because if they could do it you can too
you just have to decide
that one life isn't fair and that's okay
and two I'm gonna choose Excellence I'm
gonna stop being a victim of my
circumstances and I decide to make
things better for myself for my
community and for the people around me
and if you want more Evan check out his
top 50 rules video the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
we'll see you there